[Music]
and communicate with us in our own
language did you say that they would
turn blue yes of course wow you capture
something of the cat perhaps because you
yourself are an outcast
were you painting something here's
something funny miss wayne not at all
louis wayne was a very celebrated cat
artist an extraordinary human being a
brave um and courageous man who was
different in a time of conformity mr
wayne i have been called here because
your sister is concerned for your health
he definitely struggled with slippage
between the imagined and reality and
often at times of crisis in his life
this is the drowning scene in the latter
half where louie's
suppressed grief is starting to catch up
with him louie i'm writing to you now
because i want you to come home
he's already experienced a lot in new
york that has unhinged him and he has a
mental breakdown
as a kid he suffered from
night terrors and recurring nightmares
chief among them
was what he referred to as the sea full
of big ships where he imagined himself
drowning in a stormy ocean surrounded by
sinking vessels
and this is the moment where the
nightmare starts to manifest in a very
frightening way
in the making of this film we always
wanted to
try to imagine as best we could
how it must have felt to be him and to
try to let the audience in on that
experience we wanted to film the scene
in as visceral and immediate way as
possible so a lot of the techniques we
use are in camera we knew that
part of the scene would need to be shot
on a semi-dry set which was built in our
studio
and so we could fill that set up with
water kind of to about ankle height we
also used some back projection so the
stormy sky that you see through the
porthole is back projected
[Music]
you have this incredible score grabs you
by the neck and doesn't let you go it's
a beautiful piece of work really
accentuating the distress of louis in
that moment
the other part of the scene was shot in
a water tank and susie davis and her
team
the designer and her team had to
find a way to sort of lower this set
uh into the water
you know the one thing i'll say about
benedict is that you know aside from
being an extremely versatile gifted
actor he's also
incredibly courageous
and sort of fearless
and so i was really impressed by how he
was performing even to the point of
being fully submerged
there is a moment where because of the
the level of emotion of of crying and
collapsing underwater i'm letting out a
lot of air a lot of energy and so
there's a very small gap at the end of
committing to that to then find your way
out not panic or find the air piece and
i'm a diver i've done this but it's very
different when you're in character
he thinks that the ship he is on is
sinking
we revisit that very pivotal scene in
the middle of the movie where emily
tries to give louis what she thinks he
needs to get through the rest of his
life
the world is full of beauty
and it's up to you to capture it
we really wanted to give you just enough
to long for that moment but also to hold
enough back that you felt shared in that
frustration and shared in that sense of
loss
some of the examples of where we try to
give the audience a glimpse into the
inside of louie's mind
and some of these
memories i suppose you could say
we would shoot we'd project and then
shoot back onto 16 millimeter film
and sometimes it would be clean
processed and often we would use that
for kind of the dreamy more romantic
moments but there are some shots in this
sequence where the film was actually
hand processed james holcomb is one of
the few people who still hand process
his film in the uk
he would treat the film with the
deliberate roughness and kind of scrunch
it up and put acid in the bath
and so it would come back with kind of
deliberately corrupted colours and you
see the sort of synaptic
distressing of the material which
i guess again the hope was to really let
the audience in on
the extremity of those emotions and the
depth of distress
that louis wayne was suffering at the
time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
screaming for help from your mother and
your father
it brings back memories of childhood uh
feeling abandoned and lost and isolated
and needing help and to think of a grown
man doing that in a time of need um
it was really disturbing and
it took me to where i needed to get to
just let things
come through and lose myself to it
i hope that the audience feels a sense
of empathy with him and a sense of
understanding why i felt like for him to
contend with these demons
was so heroic and why i felt so moved to
tell a story one of the tragedies is
that if he were alive today he would
probably be an accepted extraordinary
celebrated artist and someone who would
have been supported in those darker
moments
i think you're the first person to see
the cats are ridiculous
frightened
and brave
like us
[Music]
[Applause]
you